okay so someone help me out I will start
you by saying that theater there is the
unknown so I'm just gonna call it theta
and then you're gonna have to give me
some lengths right what lengths can we
put on to here so I'm gonna tell me the
first like they tell you is what 30
meters right where's that
that's our height there so that's I'm
gonna call that 30 meters what's the
other length 4 kilometers but I'm not
gonna write down 4 kilometers because
I've already locked myself into a unit
of measurement here so I'm going to
write the 4000 where am I gonna put it
across the bottom it's that horizontal
length so 4,000 meters so now we're
going to make a statement right we're
just going to pull that out right angle
triangle trick what did you write yep
louder sir yeah thank you very much
and you can see here right and by the
way I will permit you to have terrible
scale on this because you know I'm not
going to do something to scale when it's
4,000 at this point because we've
established we've got small theta there
right so what can I say theater is
approximately equal to just just that
guy right theater and tan theta for
small values of theta are gonna be
pretty much the same so I'm gonna go
ahead and I'm gonna simplified it to 3
and 400 but don't forget and I think
it's actually important you should write
this even though it's implied
there's units that come along for the
ride right this is radians when you
don't provide an angle now that you know
what radians are you should assume it's
implied to be in radians but when you
provide them because you're going to be
going back and forth between them if I
were you I mean there is a symbol for it
but number one almost no one uses it and
number two it looks very much like a
degree sign so I never actually do that
I always write that can someone actually
tell me because you they don't want an
answer in radians do they they want an
answer in degrees so how did you did you
get a conversion where'd you get can
someone actually tell me give me a
calculator readout because this is a
good point to say something right you
get a zero first don't you get a zero
and then what degrees do you get another
zero
do you really I expected to get
something here 25 then do you get I
think you've got like a minutes here
right and then where you get after that
that's the important part
forty-six point nine nine what say no
nine and then there's probably the
double - right now this is a good point
to remember because we haven't looked at
this for a while right this is going to
be one of the most confusing kind of
things that's handed to you in anyway
because you've got measurements in lots
of 60 lots of 60 lots of 60 and then
you're like haha decimal right so that's
why you can see this is actually going
to be the forty six point nine nine that
actually rounds careful there are 60
seconds in a minute so this is like 47
of those seconds so 47 is clearly closer
to 60 isn't it right so this is in fact
not 25 minutes it's actually 26 there's
a minute s-- yeah degrees minutes a
second yeah that's sneaky easy thing to
get wrong that's why it's so important
to write that line before your
approximation because if you're lucky
right there's pretty much only one spot
that we look for approximation we don't
tell you which one it is we just say
it's only one otherwise you get docked
like 10 times so if you're lucky and you
approximate this wrong but you had this
written down at least I can give you a
thumbs up if you didn't write this you
went straight to 25 sorry that's just
it's not it's not the air time and I
can't see what you do all right does
anyone have any questions at this point
your brain feeling okay it's not that
complicated is it like you just make
sure you enjoy your diagram clearly peak
your approximation and then use your
rounding in units carefully okay
so these are the applied situations
right you're gonna have to draw a
triangle facing in different directions
but that's basically yeah let's actually
rewind so this is I've even written
these up just so you can see it don't
have to flick back one page reappear
these what we mean by these pure
questions theoretical right these don't
seem to apply it to anything it's just
kind of these are related to limits
we're just going to see what we can do
this is the limit stated as vanilla as
you can be right so what's this equal to
this is the result we put a box around
it's just one right but then very
quickly they're like what if it doesn't
exactly match up what if it's not
exactly this particular combination or
it doesn't include turn all that kind of
thing when the numbers don't match up
you're just gonna have to
fiddle with this so the numbers do match
up right so we want this theta and this
theta to match so I want it so that I
could write this 3x on sine 3x if those
angles match I'm good now of course you
can't just change it to 3x because you
want to write what we'll have to do to
this to turn that into a 3 well I'm
gonna have to multiply by something
right and I think I want this 3 to
cancel with something and then actually
end up with 5 right because that's what
you started with right I don't want
there to be a 3 there and I do want
there to be a 5 bit do you see that's
where I've come from right 5 thirds of
that would take me back to my original
question but of course 5/3 5/3 is
independent of X isn't it like whatever
X is equal to 5/3 is equal to 5/3 he
doesn't care right so in fact you can
actually take that limit out like so or
sorry you can take that fraction out of
the limit that 5/3 I've just factorized
it out and now you've got what we've
been dealing with right that's that
theater on sine theta then we were
searching for it just so happens that
our theater is 3 X just a minor point
it's a very neatly thing but I'm just
going to encourage you to do this
because I know in an HSE past they
looked for this you could say well
that's clearly 5/3 that is that's what
the answer says but I want you to
actually evaluate this thing I know it's
equal to something trivial but I want
you to say I know what that's equal to
it's equal to an object I didn't just
make it disappear and then you can say
all right that's 5/3 that's a bit of a
small thing to really worry about but
someone once upon a time actually not
someone on what if someone's lost to
Mike because they didn't put that one in
the HSC so sometimes they're looking for
a particular thing I'm just gonna wave
the flag now